each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
welcome everybody it is a pleasure to
have Olivier Peoria I watched your name
I thought I could do it right Perera yet
thank you um my apologies here from
University of Catholic and levain in
Belgium where he was a professor Olivier
has done a lot of great work on election
system is especially the helio system
where he's done a great deal of
development and was principal in getting
it used in an election when I think
25,000 eligible voters something like
5,000 people actually voted for the
university president they are so this
took an extraordinary amount of work to
make it happen but this is a real little
the largest ever real use of a
end-to-end verifiable loading system and
we're all very pleased about this movie
has also done a lot of work in related
systems and making privacy better and I
think that's what we're going to hear
about RG today so welcome thank you very
much for this very kind introduction I
will indeed talk about a privacy in
voting please feel free to interrupt me
at any point if you find it useful so
this is joint work with david burnett
ave roni katya vaca valley dermatitis
and bogdan valinsky so I would like to
talk about privacy in general it was
introduced in most of our countries
during the 19th century as a requirement
for public elections in order to avoid
this kind of situation with public
voting where you have a lot of people
strongly suggesting to voter to vote in
one sense or another and since the vote
was public they could just actually
check what the voter was doing so in
many places on the 19th century people
decided to
introduce secret ballot elections in
order to prevent corrosion and bribery
it has also some other benefits but I
recommend that maybe at some later point
so we want to have secret ballots that's
what does it mean the first of your
thing with voting is that the secrecy of
the ballot is not something that is just
completely absolute if all the voters
vote in the same way in most of the
voting system that are currently used we
will know that all voters supported the
same candidate with one hundred percent
of the votes and that's not seen as a
breach of privacy from the voting system
so it's not something like an absolute
privacy definition like we have for the
security of an encryption scheme we want
something that is weaker another
approach of defining the privacy of the
vote would be inspired from the work on
secure function evaluation the idea
would be then to say something like the
voting system should not leak anything
about the votes besides the outcome of
the election as it's written in the
White House so that's certainly a good
approach for defining the security of
cryptographic Verdean we would like to
say more about privacy in the sense that
we would like to see how much voting
system actually leaks when it's used in
a normal way we would like to know how
much the outcome of the election
actually least in terms of information
about the votes another approach for
defining vote privacy was proposed by
christos and I'll at like Tripoli
security and privacy last year and they
measure the privacy of voting system as
the maximum probability that an
adversary has to be to win the game
where he has to decide whether voters
voted in one way or in another way so
that looks like semantic security
definition in CVS security definition
for encryption
we don't require a negligible
probability of winning the game there
for that reason essentially but it seems
that that definition is too strong in
many cases for instance if you have
approval voting on complex ballot you
have I don't know 50 choices that makes
a lot of different ballots if you will
not have any voters to make sure that
all of the possible ways of feeling the
ballots are represented and if you use
that definition in that context this
definition will just tell you you have
no privacy at all which is not quite
what we want we want to say okay we have
this set of ballots and we still don't
know which of those ballots was
submitted by that voter so we want
matrix should say that there is some
amount of privacy left so I what is it
that we really want to measure in them
yeah what's the election outcome is it
thus also won by a large majority and
you stopped counting gives it a thousand
blows and after 700 both balls you got
650 right i can start counting there are
there it doesn't make you the syrian and
then less information leaks it could be
it depends on how you decide to have the
regulations typically of the election by
lowes were required to say how many
votes each of the candidate received
understand this right in bellows is
different they only get a count of your
thick cash am so effective area okay
okay okay that might be part of the
difference where you who wanted an end
by approximately what margins yeah
changes
certainly I will have examples on that
line data as long as we're stopping I
can't resist mentioning one of my
favorite examples which is an election
it's almost unanimous except for one
because in that case that one person
knows exactly how everybody voted but
nobody else is quite sure and that's
accepted from the aqha yeah that's true
okay so we want to measure privacy for
any voting system so what's the kind of
thing that we would like to know so one
first question that we may want to ask
is with what probability can my
adversary gets my vote so that's the
kind of thing that we can measure with
min entropy that might be a natural
approach for that second question is in
how many ways can I pretend that I have
voted so if in case somebody wants to
force me to vote in one way or another I
would like to know which amount of
freedom I have into claiming that I
voted in one way or another so uh that's
the kind of thing that is measured if
you use hardly entropy so we seem to
have at least here to natural questions
and two answers that look like entropy
seems to be a right an interesting
direction so we explored that direction
I will just introduce a few notations
before coming to to our definition so we
suppose that we have a distribution d
400 votes are we may not we may know the
distribution or we may not know it it
will depend on the context but if we
know it we can capture rate then we have
a target which is what the address that
we would like to learn about the honey's
voiced so the target is a function that
starts from the support of the
distribution of the others volts and
goes to something whatever it's what the
address we'll try to get so one example
would be okay the target of the
adversary's to guess the votes of the ID
Porter another target of the adversary
would be to say I would like to know
whether those two guys voted in the same
way or not
another target would be I would like to
know if the population in that specific
area voted in that way rather than in
any other way so uh that's something
extremely general and then we have this
function row that is any function that
takes all the votes and provides the
outcome so that might be each of the
candidates received that many votes or
it can be this guy's the winner it can
be a lot of things and then eventually
we have the view of the adversary which
is a random variable we have the
distribute one specific adversary we
have one distribution on the harness
both and we have a specific protocol
that we play for the election so that
captures the view of the address airy
here and from that we propose a family
of measures of privacy which are as
follows so we have here a measure em
with X which can be a variant of that
measure will come on that later so we
want to measure the amount of privacy on
this specific target for this specific
distribution of the owners votes and in
that specific voting system and we say
that this is the minimum of an amount of
entropy taken on all possible
adversary's that is left on the target
when the address re has this view and
also views the outcome of the election
so this F X is something that is left
open for the moment but really the idea
is how much information do I have about
the target given the view of the
adversary we take the world's possible
adversary so the question now is how do
we define this FX general idea would be
to say FX will be some sort of
conditional rainy entropy on a given B
that's very fuzzy so let's go to maybe
some more concrete examples so are here
are possible choices
so if we go for Shannon entropy that
doesn't seem to lead to any practical
interpretation if we go for traditional
conditional entropy that doesn't seem to
provide anything useful a either so one
notion that seems to be informative is
average mean entropy that's the notion
that comes from a paper by digital
essentially that gives you expressing
bits the probability that the adversary
guess is the targets you just have the
traditional mean entropy here and you
take the expectation here on all
possible views that can happen on that
side ok so that's one measure another
one that seems to lead to practical
interpretation is what we call min min
entropy we still have mean entropy but
here we consider the worst possible view
that is given to the adversary so that
captures the case where we would like to
know the amount of privacy that the
voters keep even if all harnessed voters
do the exact worst possible choice in
terms of privacy so if all the voters
vote for the same candidate we would
like to know how much entropy is left on
the target so what's the probability
that the adversary guesses his target in
the worst possible case a third possible
notion is what we call min hardly
entropy so that's again a worst case we
take the minimum over all possible
choices by the voters but now we simply
count the number of possible values that
the target can take in this worst case
so an interesting thing of this measure
is that it has no probability at all is
just taking into account the support of
the distribution so
possible votes essentially but we do not
need to assign any probability to any
specific vote so when this is not now
that's a convenient measure to use ok
solo Nets let's see on simple examples
the different feelings that we get from
those three measures so we'll take
something extremely simple or prove out
voting one single question so I am sorry
either yes or no 013 voters I assume
that vote that they vote uniformly at
random and the targets for the address
re is the choice of the first voters so
you would like to know how the first guy
voted and we consider four different
darling words so in the first case the
tally is just a constant is something
that is independent of the choices of
the voters and in that case whatever
measure we take as expected we get one
bit of entropy there is one bit the
voter choose between uniformly between
two two different values so uh one bit
of entropy second thing is just saying
who the winner is so we tell whether
there are more one choices than g0
choices which is essentially what you
proposed then we see a few changes um if
we start from here which is the easiest
solution we see that in terms of Outland
Trophy we still have one bit because if
I know that I have more roads for one
then verse 40 there is still a
possibility that the first voted voted
80 1 or 0 the to remain options so we'll
still have one bit of hardly entropy if
he goes if we go for the min min entropy
then we see that we have a substantial
decrease this is essentially because if
I need if I see that outcome I have a
fairly good probability of guessing how
the first vote vote
what happens is that I have if I know
that there are more once than zeros I
can see that there are essentially three
possible ways of getting more ones and
zeros that give a one vote for the first
voter and one single that gives 0 vote
for the first voter so the point for is
essentially minus libraries of three out
of four and if you compute here for the
average case we obtain the same numbers
for different computation so in the
average case I have one case where now
actually this is just a yes symmetric we
know who the winner is and we don't know
how much more and since this is
completely symmetric we have the same
number on both sides so the turtling
function is how many yes vote happened
and how many even know what's happened
so um this time the min heartland
through P becomes 0 because there is the
case where everybody votes one or
everybody 40 so since this is worst case
we have no entropy left on this side and
in terms of min min entropy we have zero
as well for the same reason there is a
worst case in which I can guess with
certainty but now in the average case I
still have some entropy because there
are cases where I cannot guess I can
guess but I can be sure so I keep some
amount of entropy in that case in the
average case and so eventually this is
the function that gives all the votes of
everyone and I have no entropy left
anywhere so these seem to correspond
with on or intuition at least so we can
measure quite a lot of things we can
compare different tallying rules using
this kind of matrix see how they be have
and we actually decided to go for one
particular example we consider the
scanty gritty voting system
so scanty gritty has been used in a
municipal election in Takoma Park in
maryland team 2009-2011 it's an
end-to-end verifiable voting system it's
a paper-based voting system so the
ballots look like traditional paper
ballots you have ballots on which you
indicate your choices the only
difference is that when you want to to
pick a candidate you use those special
pens that reveal some invisible ink and
so when you select that candidate here
you will see appear some letters that
make a code and the idea is that this
code is something that you should write
down on a take home receipt and you will
be able to use those codes to verify
that your paper that your ballot is
properly recorded and there will be an
early trail that will allow you to to
verify that the outcome is correct so in
those elections are what is required by
the bailout the official outcome of the
election is the number of votes that
each took of the candidate received so
that's one level of privacy that we may
want to measure but actually if you look
at the effect of using scintigraphy we
see that we have more information that
is really revealed one thing that is
revealed is that the each individual
ballot is revealed in the clear so these
are shuffles so you do not know which
ballots comes from who but you see you
see the ballots essentially a second
thing that you can see is that you have
those taken receives so this they are
supposed to be something that you can
show to everyone the system is supposed
to be received free so if you see
someone with a certain number of goals
and it's receive you know how many
bullets were filled by the person so
that gives you again a bit more
information isn't it the case that we
take her receipts filled out by hands
could add extra college they could they
certainly could I'm not sure that adding
extra cause would be extremely effective
because there if you checked on the
bulletin board you will see which could
happen and do not happen but that could
be yeah you could it's not part of the
instructions but you could okay so we
did some analysis we took the tacoma bug
due to the nine election data i just
have some numbers gathered here just to
give a sense there were six different
words so i have our first fifth and
sixth which are represented here i just
took three of them to show that the
number of voters differ quite a lot
between the different words so if you
take the first word we have 470 votes
that have been collected in the fifth
world you only have 85 votes that have
been collected there were two questions
four in each word so question 0 question
1 and then we can check the official
outcome and we see that actually in
other words all candidates received at
least one vote so we have the maximum
amount of entropy everywhere are six
bits of entropy corresponds to three
possible choices three-point 17 bits of
entropy corresponds to two possible
choices it's you can rank the candidates
so that's why you have more
possibilities that just for approval
then you can wonder what's happening if
you take a look at the receipts then we
see that the amount of entropy decreases
quite a lot and in particular we see
that in the word 54 question 0 there is
no entropy left this actually means that
for one of the voters at least if that
person shows her take on receipt we know
how that person voted because
essentially that person is the only one
to have
filled a certain number of ballots on
his ballot so if we see the size of
those ballots it seems that normally we
would not expect this to happen but in
practice people really do not vote
uniformly so there are really specific
ballots that happen all the time and
very few people vote differently of the
others in those elections at least so I
think it's an interesting thing to to
maybe do some routine evaluation of
those entropy matrix and election data
to see how much are the privacy might be
impacted by some may be an expected
effect due to non uniform voting ways
out or things like that okay so um
that's further essentially the first
part of my talk no second part i would
like to talk about cryptographic voting
so all matrix now are just purely
information theoretic take some
questions and oh sure I've got a few
things in trying to ask about what what
is is there a way of accounting for
partial information if I know how some
of the voters voted but not others how
does that figure too much blood like the
example I gave I know the one voter who
voted yes then I know everybody else who
voted no that gays but partial
information if you have that essentially
you will include this in the D isolettes
distribution yes
isn't that a view of the adversary
morning what you knowing that actually
it's not if I understand properly your
question you know that some guy wrote in
one specific way that's not given by the
system it's something that you know in
advance or that is revealed outside of
the system so that's something that we
would typically include in the
distribution on the honey sports another
question I have is another way that this
could be done just trying to see how we
do it together is you take an election
and you take to voters who wrote it
differently in some way mm-hmm and you
reveal their clear text votes and you
say you ask an adversary with an
adversary has a chance substantially
greater than fifty percent say others
determining which boat or cast which of
those two okay that said capture you
don't need to worry about it the
information given by the outcome you're
just looking at with the system it will
tell you something it will not tell you
the cases where you want to avoid
signaling for instance you want to
measure that there are 2 240 ways of
filling the ballots and you have a
review for us so you would like to say
okay I do have do not have 40 bits of
entropy so that part you will not have
it captured but your suggestion will
actually come something inspired by this
a bit later Oh any other question
okay okay so now we would like to move
to cryptographic voting individual
voters and threats to individual voters
the target could be more than one
individual voter right the target could
be anything book or example scales where
the group folders yes I recall I seen
the poor spokeman government spoke with
the yes it's okay when a building both
the wrong way we'll fix the elevators
after the next war I did that makes
sense but it could be captured ah yeah I
heard about stories in ccds will
individuals after yom kippur wars over
the room or ins in the army the avett
haven't had enough communist vote and we
pulled out it out of africa in a hurry
it was very popular doing pulled out of
africa okay so um cryptographic voting
protocols um i would like to consider a
class of voting systems probably the
most common class of cryptographic
voting schemes which include hideous for
instance which follow this general
pattern strongly simplified but that's a
general ID we have trustees set of
trustees they generate a public key
private keeper taking the private key
for them they send the public key
broadcast the public key then each
devote each of the voters take the
public key and then using some
encryption mechanism taken in a very
broad sense something that is
essentially a ballot preparation
protocol they take the vote dating the
public key and they produce an encrypted
ballots which might contain some zero
nourish proves or other stuffs and they
send that to to the trustees and then
the trustee will run some tiling
protocol that can be also a lot of
things and they will publish the outcome
of the election so that's just
the general idea of many schemes lady
one originally mix okay yeah that makes
sense okay I should add him on top of
the list so the problem if we want to
apply or entropy measures on that is
that we will just not get any privacy at
all because if we take any information
theoretic entropy metric we have an
adversary who sees the public key and
then an encryption of avoid using that
public key there is no entropy left on
the votes from that the vote is just
completely determined from the
ciphertext so uh that's not quite useful
so for that reason we decide to move to
some computation and analog of entropy
there are many ways of defining disks
that appear in the literature we took
one way essentially we say that for some
kind of measure of entropy f we have an
amount of computation and entropy that
is at least are on the value a given B
if and only if there is some random
variable B prime that is computationally
indistinguishable of B and we have at
least our bits of entropy using the
corresponding information theoretic
anthropometric but with the distribution
be prime given to the adversary so in
particular if you want to apply this
definition to that example we can say
that the radar at leasts are bits
entropy on the votes here given this
ciphertext if there are at least are
bits of entropy when the view of the
adversary's actually an encryption of a
constant instead of having an encryption
of the votes because traditional
encryption schemes will make this
indistinguishable of that so we can then
have computational analog or of four
pieces metric this is exactly the same
as before
except that we have computational matrix
here and a see over there so that's just
the definition the problem is that it
seems much more complicated to evaluate
a metric like this essentially because
we need to to find out to define somehow
this B prime and that's something that
you cannot just sample maybe or it's
more complicated so what we would like
to have is some convenient way of moving
from computational entropy to
traditional information theoretic
entropy and at the same time maybe
removing all those stuffs are that are
part of the protocol so we would like to
get rid of the cryptography and say or
particle is good if we have an amount of
computational entropy that matches the
level of information theoretic entropy
that is obtained when we just see the
tally so for that purpose we decided to
go for a classical cryptographic
security game which is something that
looks maybe a bit more complicated mad
but it's much easier to use in
cryptographic security proofs so the
game is as follow we have an adversary
we have a challenger or on oracle this
oracle chooses a private key public
keeper just like in the actual voting
particle and it chooses a bit better the
goal of the address will be to guess
that bit better so the first thing that
the oracle does is send the public key
to the address sorry like in a regular
election and then the adversary can do
two different types of queries so the
first type of query is a vote curry so
these are essentially modeling the votes
of the honey's voters those vodka is
contained two different volts which is
kind of in the direction of your
nutrition before
and now what theoretical will do with
those to vote intentions here he will
run the normal a ballot preparation
procedure from the protocol so he will
produce to encrypted ballots and then he
will have two built-in bar so built in
both zero nobility bought one and he
will place those two ballots on the two
corresponding between boards but
depending on the value of betta the
adversary will just see one of those two
building boards and so that's where the
adversary see something that is related
to beta and he needs to get somehow
which of the two built-in bar CCS so
that's one type of queries second time
of query is ballot query so here that's
somehow cons for the address I'll
adversarial votes gareth re can just
produce whatever he wants and maybe not
following the bella preparation rules
and since those are encrypted ballots
that might just mean nothing at all or
could be computed from things that the
adversary cells on the building board he
has a lot of freedom for that and now
the Oracle will just apply the protocol
to check whether this is a valid
encrypted ballot if there is something
describing the protocol in terms of
verification procedure and if that is
valid he will post this be on the two
built-in bars again the adversary just
sees the between both better updated
goats are prepared by adversary
here no by the Oracle these are I've
vote for this candidate these are clear
vote be 0 and V 1 and the Oracle perform
their the encryption confuse proofs and
and all those things while here this is
a real cipher text and the proofs are in
there so essentially in this case your
record knows what will be displayed on
the between world in that case ah that
might not be so clear so we have the
address where you can place those two
queries many times in whichever order he
wants and then eventually when he is
done he says okay I would like to see
the tally and now the Oracle will just
show the tally of the building board 0
always the same so that's essentially
preference trivial distinctions that
could happen with the adversary I don't
know we might be willing to say I want
to see the tally better but if we do
that with just one vote query with two
different votes from the tally d
adversary would be able to to know the
better so he sees one outcome and we say
that a voting system is secure offers
privacy if the probability that you
adversary guess is better is essentially
one half plus something negligible so
that looks like a traditional
cryptography game more convenient to
prove using cryptographic tools and we
can actually show that if cryptographic
protocol satisfies that's definition
then we have what we expected so what we
expected more formally was something
like this consider a telling function
row so that's the outcome that is
expected to be computed from the votes
and from this we have an ideal voting
protocol in which voters submit their
votes perfectly privately to the trustee
and the trustee reveals our role of all
the votes so that's the ideal voting
system and what we can prove is that if
you have a voting prodigal pie that
satisfies or crypt
graphic game before then for any target
in any distribution the metric that we
have on this is equal to the metric if
we evaluate just on the outcome of the
election so to the ideal particle so no
crop geography on that side which is
what we wanted to achieve we still have
something that is computational here in
most practical cases the computational
will be just equal to the bill
information theoretic thing we have it
because the tallying function we did not
say anything about it it might be
something that in itself contains crazy
cryptographic stuffs and in that case we
still have something ah that is
computational but for most practical
tallying functions that will just be the
information theoretic fashion ok so it's
210 yeah maybe I can know the next
natural question will be to say ok we
have this cryptography game we would
like to know whether a voting system
that follow this line satisfies the
cryptography game so what do we need to
do essentially in terms of encryption at
this step to have to have it that are no
address that we will be able to win here
ok um so the first intuition might be ok
we just have two votes and the address
re needs to guess which one this looks
like in GPA security or something like
that so maybe secure semantic security
would be good enough actually it's not
the case so here is the kind of things
that could happen first the adversary
currys for a vote 40 then and vote for
one so what the address three C's on the
building board is an encryption of 80 0
1 depending of the bit better and now
the adversary says ok we'll just take
that cipher text
no what is it what is encrypted here but
I will just use it in a ballad query an
hour as for the tally and we can check
that the tally will be equal to better
so that's certainly something we want to
prevent so um how do we prevent this one
way would be to say the authorities to
just reject all duplicate cipher text we
do not want people to take a ciphertext
and resubmit it the problem is if we use
just a traditional in CP encryption
scheme it might very well be home a
morphic in which case people can take
ciphertext and do some real encryption
procedure and transform one cypher text
into another encryption of the same
thing and that would not be detectable
so we want to have something stronger
from the encryptions you want to make
sure that people cannot transform a
ciphertext at AC and then if we are sure
that they cannot transform the
ciphertext that AC we can apply a rule
that says we reject the duplicates
because that the only thing that is left
so what we want is some form of non
malleability from the encryption scheme
so other people looked at this before
and in at least two different papers
recent papers the conclusion was that if
you use in CCA to encryption which is a
fairly strong form of non mera bility we
are good that's okay that's good news at
least we have a notion that we know how
to to have satisfied by an encryption
scheme and we have a secretary proof for
that the difficulty is that if you look
at most of the actually deployed our
most of the protocols that have been
proposed for doing voting using the
lines the your project presented before
that people use an NCP encryption scheme
exponential game alibi encryption and
then they use a sigma prove knowledge of
the plaintext are usually something that
is made an interactive using the future
Mary heuristic the problem if you use
that is that we do not know how to prove
that this year
since eca to encryption this is well
explained in a paper by Chopin General
John Ellis cryptology 2002 there are
some kinds of proving unusual models I
would say but we do not know how to
prove that this providing CC to secure
it in any common model so there are two
approaches to that either we say okay
let's change all those schemes and move
to a real in CCA to scheme or let's
check whether this is actually necessary
can we have some weaker form of non-
ability and what we proved is that
actually we do not need in CCA to
encryption r NM cpa encryption which is
a much weaker form of non mobility is
actually good enough and we also proved
that if the strategy of the authorities
is to reject exact copies of ballots
then that form of non-availability is
actually are necessary as well so NM CPA
is essentially a characterization of
what r is needed to submit ballots in
voting system so we have a weaker notion
of non-availability and then the good
news is that it's much easier now to
show that if we have an NCP encryption
scheme el-gamal by ear whatever and then
we have those traditional sigma proofs
made an interactive is using Shh amir
then we have an MCP security the
conclusion of that sour corollary of
that for practical encryption voting
scheme if you take hideous for instance
is that if we do the future may
transform slightly differently from the
weights down their butts really minimal
change then the submit ballad submission
security procedure using Helius
satisfies the cryptographic game that i
presented before
so um okay that's what I wanted to say
about a cryptographic privacy is not
done uh yeah actually if the way it's
done not all the expected inputs are
part of the input of the hash function
that is used in the future may transform
and actually that an impact of that is
that the zero knowledge proves that I
used there on that sounds and that
essentially breaks the reliability of
the scheme so it's really an important
thing to do that changing Helius it's
not that we cannot prove the security of
the scheme is just that the scheme
there's insecure and we need to change
it to have the proof working exactly
it's on the way thank you will be all
the vulnerability previous uses of here
so yeah that's great okay one last thing
I wanted to discuss is the balance
between privacy and verifiability so are
like sure said I have been involved in a
fair amount of universally verifiable
elections and this could sit with a lot
of people who were considering adopting
and to end verifiable voting systems and
one of the big concern that essentially
made some people at least are not go for
universally verifiable encryption was
the presence of a building walls so if
you take the first ideas that the people
have when when they want to go for an
internal voting system for instance it's
ok we'll just encrypt or votes will send
over to a server and the server will
announce a tally and now you would like
to make that very fair but ok that's
good and now you also would like to
display all the ciphertext on a web page
why would you want to
do that because that what provides
verifiability from those ciphertext we
can verify that the outcome matches all
the ballots and cryptid ballots that
have been submitted by the people oh no
we don't want that because at some point
your cryptography will be broken or the
machines will become too powerful
everyone will be able to decrypt
everything and we do not want the voting
system to just provide a vector that
makes it easy for everyone to just
download all the ciphertext and wait
until some cryptographic break to
happens and allows to just decrypt
everything or wait until there is enough
computational power to just do some kind
of brute force attack so one question
that came there is okay can we now offer
a university verifiable voting system
without impacting the privacy of the
original thing that people have in mind
can we just add verifiability as a new
feature that doesn't impact the other
previous features of the scheme so one
ID for doing that would be as follow we
consider first the private building body
you can view that private building
borders essentially the voting server
it's where the people submit their
encrypted ballots and that's essentially
the view that people have for the non
verifiable voting system we have
computational privacy with respect to
these very selected authorities who
control the footing server now we would
like to add this public very bored
that's what will be used for universal
Wi-Fi ability but now there do not need
to be any way of actually computing the
outcome of the election we can just have
something that allows verifying the
outcome of the election so we could have
information theoretic privacy on that
public building board and that's way the
public building boat just contains
something that is are statistically
independent of jetrel votes so in
practice if we have information
theoretic privacy on the bulletin board
that means that we will all
so have computational verifiability of
this board but it seems much less
dangerous because it means that if the
cryptography is broken in 20 years
people will be able to forge proofs or
claim that the ability the public
bulletin board indicates another winner
but nobody will believe that because the
cryptographic proofs are not sound
anymore after 20 years so uh that seems
much less damaging than being able to
say okay you voted for that guy and that
guy happen to have I don't know what bad
story could happen so to that purpose we
designed we propose the use of a new
cryptographic primitives which we called
a commitment consistent encryption so
the commitment consistent encryption
scheme is essentially a traditional a
threshold encryption scheme that comes
with two extra functions the first
function extract see takes a ciphertext
an encryption of a vote and extracts
from that ciphertext a commitment on
that exact fold typically the commitment
will be something perfectly hiding the
second feature of the encryption scheme
is that we have an extra key function
that also takes a ciphertext and that
gives you an opening of the commitment
that you got there that is consistent
with the initial voter intent so the
message that the water encrypted so just
to have a an immediate idea on how to
build something like that one way will
be too sir ki will take an encryption
and a commitment scheme I will generate
two keepers with the public key
encryption scheme I will generate one
key from the commitment scheme and now
when I want to encrypt a message or vote
I will use the commitment scheme to
compute a commitment and the exhilarated
at is needed for opening the commitment
and then I will use my two encryptions
key encryption keys to encrypt the
actual message and to encrypt using
every value that is
it for opening and so the ciphertext is
now made of the commitments and the two
encryptions so that's a simple way of
building this not very efficient way of
building this but are that really works
the two encryption schemes video vendors
say jenny was certainly is here for the
proof if they are different I dinner
check it might work with the same key
yeah should check so um if we have this
commitment consistent encryption scheme
then we can vote as fallout we take the
idea of the general idea of the voting
scheme I presented before we still have
the same first step generation of the
public key for this commitment
consistent encryption the voters now
encrypt their votes using that
commitment consistent encryption scheme
and now for our family till your
treaties will not publish the whole
ciphertext they will extract the
commitment and publish the commitment
part and now i will consider two
different ways of verifiable ways of
computing the tally to the two most
common ways one is homomorphic telling
so the idea is to take all the
ciphertext compute the product of all
the ciphertext that provides an
encryption of the outcome of the
election and we decrypt our that's
outcome so we can do exactly that thing
and if the commitment scheme is a
morphic we will just let the auditors
computer product of all the commitments
and when we decrypt the product of all
those ciphertext you will get an opening
for the project of those commitments so
now if we take the traditional approach
what the authorities need to do is to
complete computer zero knowledge proof
that they actually decrypt the product
of the ciphertext here we have something
that is simpler we just need to reveal
the opening of the the commitment no
proof
made it and know the security follows
from the binding property of the
encryption scheme other approach its mix
net-based a link so here the idea is
that the authorities take all those
ciphertext here and then they do a
verifiable shuffle of all those
ciphertext and they decrypt the outcome
of this shuffle so we can do exactly
that here we include a verifiable
shuffle proof for the other commitments
we use statistical zero nourish proofs
of the correctness of the shuffle that
most I would say most of the classical
verifiable shuffle comes with
statistical knowledge proof so that's
not an obstacle I know again we open the
shuffled commitments and the variability
follows from the binding property of the
commitments so how to build more
efficient commitment come system
encryption schemes one extremely useful
tool that we found where what people
call structure preserving commitment
schemes you might have seen this paper
over there at your crib this year these
are nice commitment scheme that have
things that makes life much easier and a
computation much more efficient so these
are commitment scheme that are based on
elliptic curve groups that support
bearings in your case we go for
symmetric bearings which are the
simplest ones so we have two groups g1
g2 and a billionaire map from g1 and g2
to to GT and now here is an example of
commitment scheme that works along those
lines for the public key we take one
generator of the first group to random
generators of the second group and when
we want to commit on a vote the
commitment part is actually computed
just like a peterson commitment the big
difference is now know the opening is
not made of
are the opening is made of G to the r
that's the convenient thing is that now
it's a group elements and that's much
simpler to mix with encryption to mix
with Sigma particles so all the zero
knowledge proofs become very
straightforward when we use this so when
committing we do not need to perform any
commitment so the voters do not need to
compute any commitments it's just part
of the audit if you want to check that
the outcome is correct that you need to
compute some bearings to make sure that
this is working fine in terms of
security the binding property of this
scheme is implied by the decisional
diffie-hellman assumption in the two
groups actually weaker computational
assumptions are needed but since we will
mix this with a gamma later everything
holds if we have ddh so um here is the
first of our two schemes this one is
designed for homomorphic telling so uh
it means that we need to have something
that is additive leoma morphic and also
that we can't elevate something where
the decryption procedure is not
efficient because what we will need to
decrypt is the outcome of election and
that's not something that is too big so
we can do exhaustive search for instance
to find it which is what we have to do
with exponential el-gamal anyway so two
generators of the two groups selected
randomly and the private key is actually
the discrete logarithm of g1 in the base
G as the private key sex one and now
very simple the commitment is exactly
what I present in the previous slide the
opening was G to the r and so we use
this el-gamal key to encrypt g to the
are so our traditional el-gamal
encryption so the commitment is this
part that's what is published and for
decryption like i said we need to
extract some discrete logarithm are in
our GT that can be done efficiently by
exhaustive search
okay so we have all the properties that
we expect this is in cpa so that means
that we can add the sigma proof to make
it an ncpa and have all the proof i
presented before working well it's
compatible with traditional tional stuy
protocols okay so maybe i will go faster
on this one so we have a second
encryption scheme that is more designed
for mix that base tulane so the
difference now is that we have large
message space we want to be able to
encrypt whatever we want but we do not
need to have an additive a mophie cloud
we just need to be able to do rien
shins we just need to have a neutral and
so by tweaking the commitment scheme we
have something that is still quite
similar a mix of El Gamal and
commitments are same properties as
before so we consider the efficiency of
those solutions so one previous solution
used in a different context ah but also
for voting but slightly differently was
better cutter was based on precedent by
a so you can see that if we take our to
encryption scheme compared to the
solution there we have roughly a factor
of 100 in steps of efficiency benefits
now think that that's not probably not
the most important benefit I think the
most important benefit of those
solutions compared to that one is that
the the Tres whole key generation
procedure for pi is something that is
quite complex here we do everything in
primal groups so we have a much simpler
key generation procedure from a
practical point of view that's important
so to conclude we have discussed
information theoretic and computational
definitions of privacy for voting we
showed a cryptography game that can be
used to bridge the two notions fairly
easily we identified an MCP a security
as the
necessary and sufficient notion that an
encryption scheme is satisfy our for
submitting ballots we shelled it the
traditional approach of using an ncpa or
morphic encryption scheme with a sigma
protocol with an interactive using fetch
Amir can offer an MCP security and then
eventually you propose new encryption
scheme that proposed we think an
interesting a compromise between
information theoretic and computational
privacy any more questions yes just a
beautiful diwali with some numbers on
java because since you had 11 dog
indoors okay um one sec yeah in
javascript and in javascript not java
right in javascript javascript okay
you're expected to leave to be 50 50
millisecond if you tomorrow yeah um yeah
and by doing a master's student at UCL
is implementing this and this is just by
using standard library and if we just
try to implement it more efficiently we
can have it much faster